[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bili Eilish usually known for covering
up in oversized clothing surprised
concert goers on Monday night in Miami
when she did this
[Applause]
each country
yeah the singer stripping down to her
bra in this big-screen video its
seemingly her way of making a statement
about body shaming and the pressures
women and music are faced with
[Music]
you decided
it is
in the haunting monologue Billy
seemingly says quote if I wear what is
comfortable I am NOT a woman if I shed
the layers I am a [ __ ] though you've
never seen my body you still judge it
and judge me for it and quote we make
assumptions about people based on their
size we decide who they are we decide
what they're worth of course Billy has
been open about her body image in the
past I get the impression you don't want
us to see your body is that true yeah me
and my body's relationship has been the
most toxic relationship you could even
imagine but she's glad people are
interested in her fashion well is it
weird that people are so intrigued and
interested it's it's really sick it's
kind of exactly what I would want people
to care about you know yeah like I don't
know the things that people sort of know
me for are all the things I want to be
known for if that makes sense cuz style
has always been something I care about
you know visuals and videos and you know
something the tour video comes after
Billy opened up about getting hate
though it's weird like the the the the
cooler things you get to do are the more
people hate you it's crazy you do still
read everything this one is to none I
stopped like two days ago just - okay
literally two days ago I have you stop
stop um I stopped reading comments fully
because because I was ruining my life
but we love to see her taking a stand
and using her platform to make this type
of statement are you ready for the next
level of superstardom no I think I am
honestly you know I think I I feel like
I feel like I am feel like I always have
been a little bit without really
realizing it your destiny
[Music]